every morning or every night before
going out definitely after the big game
for most people
showering is routine but for some it's
religion what are you getting now
but if lots of showering makes you feel
divine your body might be the real
miracle worker this is what if and
here's what would happen if you didn't
shower for a month the average human
spends more than a year of their life in
the shower and according to most
dermatologists that's way too much
but how else are you supposed to keep
looking and smelling your best while
it's no secret that scrubbing removes
dirt sweat and harmful bacteria
it also strips away natural fats and
lipids that hydrate your skin the more
you shower the less time your body has
to replenish this healthy layer of
moisturizing bacteria so if you stop
showering will your body just clean
itself um it would be healthier for you
but not for everyone else once you give
up showering you'll start to see the
difference in as little as three days
your skin will be noticeably drier and
your hair grease here one of the first
signs of progress will be that your hair
will stay in place when combed back no
product needed after going five days
without showering you should probably
start warning people before you enter a
room then again they'll smell you coming
if you're doing this challenge without
deodorant then put the savings towards a
t-shirt budget sweat stains will be so
bad that your shirts will be one wear
and throw out items after 10 days you
can throw out your comb to your hair
will be so greasy and matted that you
won't be able to run a brush through it
your scalp will be so itchy that any
relief would be welcome but at the same
time any contact with your head will no
doubt show how bad your dandruff problem
by day 20 it's hard to believe your
human friends and family no longer
acknowledge your existence and you can
barely stand your own smell let alone
your appearance days and nights of
scratching your dry itchy skin will be
obvious from the festering sores on your
body and if you thought you were past
getting acne congratulations you're 13
again you're ready to give up but just
wait a little longer by the end of the
month after only rinsing with water the
layer of healthy bacteria that your body
produces will be completely restored the
acne goes away on its own and your skin
will probably start looking better than
it did when you were showering but will
it have been worth it
probably not you still smell terrible
while sweat doesn't actually emit any
odor it does produce fatty acids and
protein that your skin bacteria feed on
and it's their metabolic process that
gives off that nasty smell so yeah keep
using soap keep showering
but maybe dial back on how often you do
it why dedicate a year of your life to
standing in the shower when you can free
up some of that time to watch more what
if
[Music]